a presença de mulheres na ciência
muita gente diz que se ele é coisa de
menina
perguntado se a criança saber se eu
queria ter sentido uma criança curiosa a
cabeça do boneco defender a médica
professora administrador advogado
o momento 50 em um colégio
mas eu também queria ser mulher
maravilha ao nível daquele avião
realizava uma corda na cintura
então a sério e uma mesma visão do
colégio o corpo de bombeiros e uma
porque eu cheguei em casa pela potência
de um diploma de coragem bravura
eu tinha faltado dessa torre quer
ultimar aquela menininha 9min chega em
casa com seus pais
ele estava bastante conceituado genial
mas eu acho que é genial que eles são
culpados claro é a seguinte fratura não
queriam saber que a cientista
eu não conheço nenhuma mulher cientista
se o número de mulheres na ciência ainda
é pequeno quando era criança era menor
ainda é muito difícil você querer ser
alguma coisa que você não sabe que
existe
eu lembro que no colégio uma vez por ano
antes se ele começar o ano colhendo de
quinta
traz os alquimistas já começaram a
estudar fenômenos químicos
eles também queriam continuar com o
sonho pra curar doenças
uma pedra aliar bom que algumas pessoas
ali com esses experimentos eles deram
início de uma ciência que eu vi os novos
horizontes curtos continente que a ficar
ali também nessa linha verde contava que
o corpo humano é uma usina que as quinas
acaba no meio dessas reações ocorre com
o ser humano continua vivo e se não na
clínica não habita uma forma física na
respiração
a onda de química que gostava de
matemática
eu gostava de física de todos explica o
pão a disciplina que ele não tem mais
afinidade
o colégio também pode gostar física
aí aquele último ano do colégio você
estaria decidindo se vai fazendo
vestibular é que você vai ser quando
crescer eu decidi que eu queria ser
kimika treino livre e 98 do curso de
querer nos dois últimos anos trabalhava
estagiária no laboratório e aí foi
quando tive meu primeiro a pesquisa
achava impressionante como os
pesquisadores aplicaram conhecimento
científico em benefício vai mostrar o
mesmo da saúde das pessoas
quando eu terminei o curso de química
sabia que eu queria utilizar
eu tinha pedido pra fazer alguma coisa
útil para a sociedade mas prometeu fazer
isso eu tinha que aprender a fazer
ciência e para aprender com as
experiências
eu tinha que fazer um doutorado em 2003
eu comecei meu doutorado na usp e com o
nome de estatísticas
eu fui procurado no grupo liderado por
uma mulher e quando cheguei lá era 60
das mulheres e apenas um estudante homem
e aí eu conhecia não tecnologia
a lei foi um dia estava no laboratório
ele orientadora dele falou
acho que é um projeto que a gente seja
comprar um microscópio de força atômica
foi aprovado e virar uma pessoa no
treinamento porque ela recebeu
treinamento tem que aprender tudo porque
depois você vai ensinar a todos
eu sabia que era uma técnica indicada
seria diversos parâmetros que controlar
para poder fazer uma medida
completamente
me preparei toda preta treinamento foi
um treinamento superou o fim do dia
depois eu fiquei sentada eu o
microscópio uma salinha pequena o ar
condicionado estava sempre com frio mas
eu fiquei lá durante semanas
cada dia eu repassava o que tinha
aprendido e aprofundando um pouco mais
até cheguei a um ponto que eu sabia para
quem funcionava cada um toca aquele
programa da microsoft era muito
interessante também como era a principal
usuária
eu recebi amostras para fazer de outras
pessoas
o desafio porque chegar naquela mostra
que eu tinha que olhar pra ela ficava o
que era e é um pouco tempo eu tinha que
começar a fazer a imagem e já tentar
descobrir qual é o nosso relevante que
eu podia tirar aquela imagem durante o
doutorado também eu me apaixonei pela
pesquisa eu vi que ela completa
o desafio sempre e ela se emociona
todas as vezes que eu vejo o fenômeno
porque eu não sei como é que eu nunca vi
que eu não entendo desperta uma
curiosidade mim eo nosso sucesso até eu
consegui entender aquele jogo cerveja
durante muito tempo enquanto fazia
doutorado e até no início nos nokia que
estava muita gente perguntava mas menina
quando você vai parar se vai começar a
trabalhar eo visual trabalho toque de
quase uma moratória que mania que a
gente tem que parar de prender a gente
pode aprender nunca nunca nunca de tudo
mas eu entendo essa pergunta
aqui no brasil o cientista não
reconhecida
se você olha de fora novamente
estudantes profissionais estão até a
hora de servir e tal mas o procurado eu
falei não
o que eu quero fazer para o resto da
minha vida
e aí infelizmente naquela época ninguém
trabalhava saiu vai encontrar um grupo
técnico que ele usava
choramos legal e que se ele podia me dar
uma falha coque
ae depois de muitos emails conversa
telefônica em junho de 2008
eu cheguei a madrid começou uma grande
aventura
desenvolver uma tecnologia para detecção
precoce do câncer
cheguei lá toda animada cheia de emoções
que eu dou as malas que tinha bastante
fofa alívio não tinha um notebook
toda minha família que vontade de
aprender nota
cheguei lá e junto comigo
chegou também a crise econômica na
europa chegando lá gostei mesmo tempo ea
espanha um dos países mais afetados pela
crise econômica
chegamos a ter noções de 25% da
população desempregada e adivinhe esse
projeto estava tão emocionado ele não
foi financiada podia fazer na pesquisa
muito normal não é muito mas não é assim
ea única coisa que a gente podia fazer
era tentar continuar submetendo projetos
dessa pesquisa financiada
mas encontrei isso eu já tinha assinado
contrato de três anos que ia fazer na
hora de um plano b que é o
desenvolvimento de sistemas óticos
justamente para impedir todas imprudente
500 que usamos
além do dia chegou e falou e aí você é
bom soldado cabo e cabo
eu já troquei existentes dinheiro mas
quando acaba nunca tinha soltado eu
falei pra ele quando fundou o primeiro
agente jeff cobre né
ele explicou que fazer me ajudou a
comprar uma peça orçamentária semana
desenhando peças montando um teste
soltando cabo e eu sou boa nessa hora
rodando carro fechando para tudo
1º t note não posso fazer isso claro
morte na itália
então vamos ver até hoje depois que
terminar de construir um sistema ótico
um projeto que a gente pediu para
desenvolver esses telefones e não
mecânico
relacionado ao câncer foi aprovado e
mandar seu time sabia é que na última
década esses sensores ele já tinha
demonstrado grande para detectar
concentrações em concentrações muito
baixas inglês e proteína
mas é como perguntar seja apresentado na
última década tanto potencial porque
ainda tão distante assim contando com
tecnologias de uma aplicação de uma
médica
a primeira coisa que o fim nesse projeto
o estudo estatístico da
reprodutibilidade desses sensores e
depois de mais de três mil medidas
eu vi que realmente os sensores eles
estão muito sensíveis mas tenho muita
velocidade que fumar pode notar como
sócio positivo falso negativos
significa que vamos lá vamos fazer um
teste de qualidade
desenvolvemos um teste de qualidade a
gente viu que era melhor que muitas
técnicas
somente em finca mas que não é não era
suficiente porque quando conversava com
alguns pesquisadores que se dedicam a
encontrar proteínas né seu marcadores
que podem indicar o início do
desenvolvimento do tumor
o número final apenas como um tamanho
proteína pensei nossa ele vai falar o
que você tem que desenvolver uma
tecnologia pelo menos 100 mil pesos mais
sensível porque as tecnologias atuais
onde saí pra esses entes
o problema é o meu trabalho
e aí comecei com o chefe fizemos umas
ideias e eu falei tá bom voltem ao
esquecimento ea gente conversa fazendo o
experimento dia tem sempre que fazer é
conversar com ele a reunião ele olhou
pra mim falou
como todo mundo
assim e articula a empresa uma coisa
tinha me falado quando era adolescente
mãe eu posso na festa não é todo mundo
mas você não é todo mundo não só todo
mundo
eu acredito que o tratamento certo
genial mas se não der certo eu vou
pensar em outra coisa
mas o que eu não vou fazer é fazer como
todo mundo porque eu nunca amei ninguém
notava se arriscado foram eu comecei a
nova igreja ferimentos mostrados eu
tinha inferiores ao final dos primeiros
sempre na sexta feira de manhã e até
internacional de errado e que eu podia
fazer um centavo sexta feira à tarde e
muito a sexta feira à noite estudando há
quem faça uma estratégia já na próxima
semana a experimento
eu voltava a cada semana
de repente um dia deu muito certo
o experimento foi feito nem a crescer
foi lá destino foi dado resultado
acho que foi um bom jogo
minha vida era difícil caminhar nos
tornar um meio que dos autos rua e aí
depois de um ano e meio de trabalho
muito duro fora como os outros pelo
menos seis horas eu conseguir cumprir
todos os segmentos e aí eu consegui
realizar um sonho muito feliz que eu
tenho eu consegui mostrar para todo
mundo que eu sei como achar agulha no
palheiro
eu sei como toda semana eu vejo que ele
saía da estatística mostra que existem
muito mais novo que é um cargo de
liderança mas eu também vejo que muitas
mulheres já começam a ser chefe de grupo
de pesquisa
eu não me vejo que lá europa o movimento
para que a gente possa alcançar uma
igualdade por exemplo em alguns projetos
que a gente comete um dos pontos que
eles analisam é serviço um bom
equilíbrio de gêneros entre os
participantes do projeto
mas o que eu mais gosto de ver as
mulheres têm um diferencial acionário
nem se apaixona e começou se apaixona
uma coisa nada do sábado
não existe obstáculo e eu vejo que
enquanto os homens caminho para atingir
um resultado nós mulheres estamos
correndo
obrigada